getting fat is easy so what there's no
there's no sacrifice but your health is
just sacrifice I don't understand how
we're not agreeing on that point I just
think we get to a point where fat people
don't want to talk about what's reality
I know why I am also plus size it is
because literally I am busy I think a
lot of people develop this mindset that
they are too far gone and then they just
never do anything about it and I can't
speak for those people because that's
not my issue I've never not fit in a
plane seat I've never had a health issue
because of my weight specifically I'm
talking about the movement in general
yeah but I'm like someone I'm saying
like being content in general is selfish
because everybody else has to deal with
the issues but being content with
yourself doesn't mean that you shouldn't
want to be better it just means that you
shouldn't have what else what else is
what else is content content as happy as
is I think it just means that you
shouldn't hate yourself like if I'm if
I'm content with my money I'm not gonna
make more money if I'm discontent with
my money then I'm going to make I think
that's a great example I'm very content
with the amount of money I make would I
like to still make more fantastic yeah I
would but you're not going to take steps
to make more money if you're content
with the amount of money in general
we're getting into semantics they won't
be if we're using the word content like
I agree with you know like being content
that you are you're stationary you're
happy no more progress but I think the
point here is that you can enjoy your
day you can go to the beach with your
friends if you want to and actually
enjoy a day on the beach with your
friends without the fact that you are
maybe not your healthiest weight or not
your best shape and allowing that to
take your day even even at the beach
like it's going to take your whether
anyone says anything to you or not it's
going to taint your day you're not going
to be able to do the same things your
In-Shape friends are gonna do
uh there's no there's no way you guys
are going to have the same Mobility as
someone as the as the trainers here if
you guys go surfing if you go tubing
like you're not going to be able to do
the same thing
so while while it might not affect you
now it might be you're young maybe it'll
affect you later but at some point life
is going to hit you and that's why I
promote eating healthy and actually
trying your bestie actually yeah I'm not
talking about you I'm talking about the
movement in general
the people different it's not different
people see different narratives it
depends what you're reading what you're
seeing and with a lot of things there's
a lot of confusion it's like people just
want to confuse you and they want people
to have discussions like this and they
want people to fight but really if you
speak to real people you get real
opinions that's how it is I don't think
it's I think it's simple I think it's if
you're fat you're unhealthy if you're
not fat you're healthy it should be as
simple as that really that shouldn't be
like oh it's confusing you know there's
going to be people like I said there's a
small amount a small percentage of
people
that you know I probably do have
conditions and and whatnot but at the
end of the day if you're fat you can
acknowledge that you're unhealthy and
you've all agreed that you want to
better yourself and and start eating
healthier whether it's training as well
so I mean yeah you can keep trying to
individualize it but at the end of the
day it's it's very it's night and day
and it's also you need to see where a
lot of people are obese the poor areas
if you look at obesity rates it's the
poor areas and what are what are the
import areas not great shops for food
it's all cheap stuff it's not good for
you are you saying the Obesity rates are
higher in in like third world countries
not third world countries but just
generally like for example when I'm
saying like that I'm just thinking if
your premise is true if we're going to
say it's about wealth then I would
imagine we would see in poorer countries
they would be fatter than in richer
countries okay for example in England
um there's Iceland's it's It's Like A
pounder meal you can get a pound ready
meal you can get um nuggets and chips
I need you to answer my initial question
though so so in third world countries
they're fatter than in the Western
countries in In There Are Places this
Fiji in general I know homeless people
with abs
there are places in the world there
where it is pouring there and they're
big
on average people in poorer countries
well not in average no it's in the UK
the western side correct so I'm saying I
don't think it's a wealthy thing okay
yeah I think it's a poor like I mean
we're the fattest in America you know
yeah but then within America what groups
of people just to get deeper on that
point I don't know if I really have an
opinion or a strong one on this but
within America or even if we take London
are we saying then the poorer people
within those places are more likely to
be unhealthy obese than the Richer
people I think it's it's uh easier for
them to get obese yeah if you're living
on like a minimum wage income and you're
gonna get fast food all the time yeah
that's probably the case in America but
there's a large portion of the
population
30 according to the CDC 38 States Plus
Puerto Rico have obesity rates above 30
percent the 10 states and territories
with the lowest obesity rates our
District of Columbia Hawaii Colorado
Massachusetts California Florida New
Jersey Washington Vermont and New York
um sound like a choice then yeah we have
to Overlay that with um like I don't
know income per household
Colorado's low obesity rate can be
attributed to culture and lifestyle many
residents enjoy outdoor activities such
as hiking as well as conscious of eating
whole nutrient dense foods for their own
well-being this is surprising to me West
Virginia is the most obese state with an
obesity rate of 40 percent West Virginia
also has a type 2 diabetes diabetes at
15.7 wow 15.7 percent of West Virginia
has Type 2 diabetes
when would be the point of okay I've got
to make a change
um when you have a health problem and
when for example
um I when I thought that I'm
pre-diabetic I instantly started
literally I consciously was like no I'm
not gonna eat no crisps I'm not gonna
eat no chocolate no I'm gonna get
diabetes and I'm gonna mess my life up
so I I reversed it and I started
drinking more water so that anything bad
flushes out and started having vinegar
and just doing random things when you
get told uh if you keep going this way
you might die that's when you're gonna
make it sweet I just listened to you and
I feel and I felt moved I think that's
what I mean when that's when I took it
seriously when I was told by the doctor
and that's a part of me being active
basically because I don't want to have
high blood pressure I don't want to have
diabetes so it's because I can't see him
at the back I feel like I can't I don't
and I was thinking I wish we sat in
there I can't see him promoted one
social media like this you will be a
happier place but for me it was when I
couldn't go down a slide I was at like a
amusement thing and I couldn't go down a
slide that my friends went down and that
was really embarrassing for me like I
was like oh uh like I am not the average
person anymore and that was a moment at
which I was like oh I want to be able to
do these things and so and I made a
video because I I knew that that would
hold me accountable on my social media
well I also think that it's a negative
consequence which kind of kind of you
might not call it bullying but that's
that's a negative consequence and it
seemed to have worked because now you're
trying to lose weight it's not from a
person though and it doesn't mean I
don't like myself
yeah it's a wake-up call and that's why
I was saying sometimes bullying is a
wake-up call I don't think bullying that
Amusement that amusement park owner was
bullying you saying it was a safety
thing that's a different thing I'm gonna
Read Super chats for uh one second
um okay Mr B no they're not they're not
bad well okay Mr
um damn another uh term to add body
neutrality SMH Haka police redheads man
found cutie slapping but doesn't respect
her uh hey you most obese people are
addicts dopamine is the real driver of
addiction food addiction is the only uh
one where you still have to use your
drug to survive difficult to overcome
but it can be done find healthy dopamine
triggers
a scout in a Bradley I find Health sexy
not too skinny not too big a crackhead
is not sexy But Lizzy isn't lizzo isn't
either
Hakata police
um uh fats will tap dance around
accountability all night Mr B they're
not acting like ladies I'm not taking
accountability uh the same way uni
doesn't guarantee a job personal
trainers don't guarantee losing weight
uh Dr David Baker and the spirit of the
body positivity movement I'd like to
announce the start of the chain smoking
positivity movement the drinking bleach
positivity movement and the put a
shotgun in your mouth with your toe on
the trigger positivity movement I love
the body positivity movement almost as
much as I love chain smoke the chain
smoking body part the chain smoking
positivity movement the drinking bleach
positivity movement and the shotgun in
mouth toe on trigger positivity movement
um hokkada police welcome to cope cast
um Ricky a donation just get just to
give a shout out to Pia family a Doug
MPA everything yeah ever everything you
get paid for everything you get paid for
should require sacrifice plus size
models don't have to sacrifice anything
that's the problem I have to go to work
every day I don't want to but I do it
hashtag lazy whales Doug MPA we I'm
sorry we we harpoon whales over here Pia
a whale attacked Pearl and we cannot let
that happen again it was attack it was
used it used to be that big girls had to
have a good attitude to counter their
weight but those days are gone Doug MPA
um body positivity really became a
movement after the the war in Iraq
started soldiers were coming back
missing limbs it was supposed to be made
for a woman or a man to wear uh a biking
Miss to wear a biking missing an arm or
a leg whales hijacked the movement
selfish whales
um what do you think about this Super
Chat everything you get should
everything that you pay get paid for
should require sacrifice plus size
models you don't have to sacrifice
anything that's the problem I have to go
to work every day and I don't want to do
it but I do it I agree with that I think
it's if what are you sacrificing for
your plus size model is a I could be a
plus size model starting tomorrow I'll
just start putting on weight get pudgy
yeah
I could make steps to towards becoming a
plus-sized model maybe it's a bit of
cosmetic surgery but just get fat and
then maybe sign up
so you just need to just stick to it
like I I feel actually hot I feel hot
but anyway could anyone be a pleasure
and I know yeah maybe if I love
somewhere I'll even be hard but I feel
happy with the way I look but if you put
on weight because people are so used to
looking at you you might not be happy
with yourself because you might be like
oh my God and then you need to learn to
love them but that's not the question is
it I do do plus size model sacrifice any
so I would respond to that a comment by
saying that person sounds more like they
have a problem with capitalism than
anything else because why are you doing
a job you don't enjoy I really love my
job I make content all day I do brand
deals I stream on Twitch I have a great
time with my life and I enjoy my
modeling
um none of that feels like a sacrifice
to me none of my jobs have ever felt
before that I worked in sales again I
really enjoyed that like I I never felt
like my life was a chore
um and it sounds more like you have an
issue with that and no I don't think
anyone could be a plus size model I need
you you need a specific look regardless
and including being plus size to be a
plus size model you still need to have
an hourglass shape I disagree you can't
be an apple it doesn't work in the past
wait wait hold on he started I'll let
you go I would say every job has a form
of sacrifice so that person that's in
the Super Chat in Works nine to five
doesn't want to go has to go Pearl being
a content creator puts in hours probably
doesn't have can socialize as much
misses out on that doesn't see friends a
model an actual model
probably has to starve herself sometimes
uh as I said work rigorous hours travel
a lot there's sacrifice
workouts are crazy yeah what does a plus
size model sacrifice why do they need
why do you need people to be unhappy to
earn their money no I would say the
general winner is that in in work when
you work you sacrifice something when
you strive for something you have to
sacrifice something what is a plus size
model sacrifice well I'm in a room with
three pts and no one's saying that the
plus size model is sacrificing her
health despite the fact that we've spent
the last hour talking about health so
she's sacrificing her you think that
should be a job then
hold the money I'm not gonna let you put
a spin on that I didn't say that that
should be you said they're sacrificing
their health no but they are sacrifice
we just discussed that if a person is
plus size and they're maintaining their
plus size like brand their identity
they're sacrificing their health because
being fat becomes a hustle now that is
the direction and I I I I guess it's not
the best way to put it a sacrifice but
it's more that like in order to get
money and jobs you should have to do
something hard and getting fat is easy
that's the easy way out and now we're
paying people to do the easy thing it's
like if I go to an NBA game and I see
below average NBA or basketball players
it's kind of like why are they there but
yeah yeah
wait wait wait wait wait but now we have
we we go to modeling shows and we have
below average bodies being modeled when
before that was like the epitome of
perfection but it's just not a skilled a
particularly skilled preference
it's a model of skilled profession I
just said that it isn't it
yeah
as well as maintaining a workout
it's not a Top Model nobody Tyra Banks
you on how to be the best
that's the company just looking for a
market to make more money but you agreed
you said that uh what what person
getting fat is easy agree
shortening your life for money
it's
air source
can I just let you know I've um taught
children swimming I was a dance teacher
um like everything I've done even me
doing my entertainment work is active
full of activism and that's how I live
my life to be active because I know when
I go to gym and when I kind of push
myself I fall apart and I go backwards
because then I'm in pain for months and
I'm in bed that's what starts happening
right but like the whole point is do
plus size models and maybe not sacrifice
is it hard to become a plus size model
before wait wait wait wait and before
like I don't know if you've ever seen
like the what I eat in a day from a
Victoria's Secret model before they were
plus-sized like their workouts it's hard
it was it required a lot of sacrifice
but it required a lot of sacrifice but
the what those damn what does Victoria
Secrets girls have done to a lot of
women is damaged them as well because
they tried being super fit like that
although they had no potential some of
them actually started taking drugs to
look look
I said three percent of the population
is underway or it's like five I don't
know but I think a lot of people's
obesity is also related to taking a lot
of this rubbish weight loss tablets and
being sold be skinny be this be that and
they have it and they they get it wrong
because a lot of the Obesity is from
remember we have the 90s was how the
noise was into actually I think that's a
victim mentality like I just think that
I don't know
a lot of rubbish was put in food a lot
of rubbish was put in food but at the
end of the day people are fat because of
their choices
that's it Point Blank period it's not
because of the food it's not because of
the water because there's ways around
all of this and with with the internet
with the internet there's no reason you
can educate yourself
what you were saying Paul though like
your initial point I just think it's
such a non-issue because one there just
aren't that many plus size models there
are a few but like in general I find
people a lot of the comments I get are
like oh my gosh thank you so much for
modeling like particularly when I
modeled a fitness wear for a bit I did a
plus size Fitness weight
um range for a well-known brand and
people were like oh this is great
because I actually know what it's going
to look like on me now as a fat person
who wants to go to the gym which is what
everyone wants is these fat people to go
to the gym what was the most well-known
fashion show
and what happened
they started putting plus size models on
the runway and everyone hated it oh
correct so we're seeing some of the
biggest fashion brands incorporate this
yeah
I just I just don't think you could say
it's a non-issue when I see them on the
cover of magazines all the time I see
them in store they even make mannequins
that are pluses
why why is there a market for plus size
now why do you guys think there's a mask
now okay what's the motive mind market
for plus size what exactly models or
plus size clothing or sorry like when
you go on online shopping and you see a
bigger person modeling the clothing why
why is that because fat people have to
wear clothes no it's because so you
think when
buy the clothes the fitting is wrong and
you know a big person didn't make it
because the car is usually funny yeah
and it's not like that with with normal
clothes so okay because fat people have
to wear clothes but that's that's the
body positivity movement because you're
now encouraging people to be at that
weight because you can buy clothes and
look like this whereas if I see a fat
model
uh you know advertising clothes I'm more
inclined not to buy it I actually click
off don't fat people deserve to know
what like if they're considering buying
I don't know a top address a laundry set
a pair of shorts whatever don't they
deserve to know what they may look like
I'm sure it's all well and good it's
great it's great for them but it's
unhealthy for them it's also nice to see
what they might look like yeah I
remember 10 years ago where man used to
sort of once a tree and to look good in
their wedding dress
is there plus size wedding dress now I
don't know
um I would say I want to add something
to the conversation in terms of why
there are more plus size models plus
size campaigns and clothing I think it's
if you look at it from the business
angle
corporations are only going to go where
the money is right exactly so if they
can see the trends and see that people
are getting fatter so obviously they're
going to be more fat people to sell to
so that also incentivizes them to create
and to support and to fund this fat uh
or that positivity they don't care about
it because then it creates even more fat
people that's the point so that's why
it's actually dangerous it's not because
you guys are looking at it from a
personal angle of or it makes me feel
better but on the larger society for
money they are nefarious acts being done
behind the scenes to make sure that
these things continue
for a company to get a plus size model
or a company to encourage you to lose
weight it's not that it's hold on we're
talking about Corporate social
responsibility now and it's not like
it's not a company's responsibility per
se to encourage fat people to lose
weight
why is it a company's selling their
products why is it a company's
responsibility to tell you not to lit up
okay responsibility to tell you should
accept right firstly why did I do that
okay can I don't think they should like
I I don't think so you've got let's say
Lloyd's bank right pride month comes
around and all these companies who
actually have nothing to do with
sexuality Lloyd's bank is just an
example that I have they throw up a
different logo with the pride flag
Incorporated that is um like a lot of
people would call it virtual signatures
bigot now because just for more
questions shouldn't do that no I didn't
say that they shouldn't do that I'm
saying no no no no listen I want you to
listen very carefully because I don't
think what I'm saying is actually that
complex so a company that has nothing to
do with like let's say health and
fitness
um let's say I don't know like a Oral B
right they make toothbrushes should they
is it their responsibility to encourage
people to lose weight and eat healthy no
they should just sell toothbrushes and
toothpaste right then so why are we
having this conversation because you
just answered your own question what was
my question if you don't remember it why
should I answer no so it was it was is
it if they're gonna do it and and hire
fat models to advertise at clothing and
and it's going to be on magazines
everywhere and it's going to be pushed
in the media that it's okay to be fat
then is it better to do that or is it
better for them to encourage people to
lose weight
they're already doing one yeah yeah
should they encourage yellow the actual
healthier out the companies that you're
talking about are only companies who
actually have business marketing to fat
people like clothing companies we're
talking like they might be advertising
train tickets and they'll have a plus
size couple and people in one school of
thought would say that's terrible you're
encouraging people to be fat and buy
train tickets it's not the train tickets
company to encourage people to lose
weight we've all just said the onus is
on the individual if you want to talk
about corporate Corporate social
responsibility we have to look at the
companies who actually profit from
people being fat what about that what
about what about marketing to kids yeah
because you think it's only a good good
message so I would say hey it's okay to
be fair I would say that the weight loss
industry are the people who profit most
from people being fat because they like
Slimming World for example so that you
keep going back into it and back into it
and back into it that's why they give
you these Point systems and they do
these things that keep you trapped
because they want you to remain losing
weight forever they don't actually want
you to get fitted I'd rather assist
industry is worse I'd rather a society
that sells weight loss pills than a
society that tells you hey it's okay get
fat and die early but I'm not gonna is
the most silliest thing you've said what
you should prefer is a world full of
greens fresh things fresh vegetables
organic stuff that's how you know you've
been watching too many magazines
are never good pills are just made up
you know if you can't choose one
yeah because his point is at least
you're going towards the ideal and
instead of saying you're okay as is not
saying that the pills are good but he's
saying he would rather live in a world
where we're at least trying to be thin
people go back to being fat you
acknowledge that you know the fact it's
true yeah the fashion industry doesn't
actually care about that plus size
because they don't when you order plus
size clothes it's poorer quality and the
cuts are just basic so the brands are
just doing what they're doing and the
biggest thing for me is why are they
still trying to keep big people like
transfers they make more money
no they don't make money because they're
just selling they're actually promoting
plus size they're just making things
that's actually popular now they make
more money no they're just making a
quick Buck because they don't actually
care there's more money it's not effort
efforts
right now the whole point isn't should
they push it it's that they do and right
now they do I don't think they do for
men you're right it's mostly to Pander
to women yeah I agree body positivity is
not a male movement it's absolutely a
female movement I I agree
yes plus size male models they're like
on online shopping sites there's plus
size male models but 100 is targeted to
more towards women because men idolize
people in good shape fitness trainers uh
people with good physiques online
because they want to go the opposite
route and get a good body to attract a
high quality woman well isn't it because
the market spend sits with women women
are like the consumers
you're right right so it's not it's not
necessarily that men it's like nothing
to do with men and being attractive it's
just that like women spend more money on
looking good no facts yeah I would say
yeah in terms of fashion 100 that's why
there's more female plus size models but
men go in the opposite direction and
want to shred as much as they can or get
in the best shape possible who's buying
more protein supplements who's buying
more weight probably not weight loss
supplements but just who's looking to
get big in the gym men
and not the not the big like fat big but
good physique big we're not we're not
stupid we know what you mean like yeah
like I'm pretty sure we're all in this
conversation and we we understand the
terminology around it I think there's
also something to be said around
treating bigger people who clearly like
are not pts and are not in the gym as
much as you guys are healthier fitter
people as if they were born yesterday a
lot of us like we know the facts it's
just that certain people are not doing
anything about it actively or some
people are on that journey and still
look big but there's a certain amount of
arrogance I think around people who are
fit and the way that they perceive
people who are unfit and how that
manifests as treatment I think which is
why like I've actually heard of that
woman who like she was really big and
she wants to buy it she thinks that
plane seats should be like three seats
wide because oh my God we spoke about a
loss right because she can't like fit in
a single plane seat like that there's a
certain amount of ignorance from fit
people towards unfit people and I think
that's why what do you mean ignorance
arrogance and ignorance like just that
clarification it's like we know what you
mean by getting big in the gym it's like
there's context that I think I don't
think he was being arrogant
almost I I think I think it's the other
way around I think the fat who are
asking for extreme on the plane are
claiming to be victims they're they're
the ones got walking around with
arrogance and saying hey I deserve
better treatment yeah whereas the fit
don't look it down on you they just look
at you maybe that you have a lack of
discipline or maybe maybe uh you could
make healthier choices I would encourage
all my fat mates to lose weight and get
in better shape that doesn't mean I look
down upon them do you think those are
back and forth between the fit and the
unfit and it's sort of like the anti
gets up to where you've got people
asking for like three literal plane
seats so that they can sit comfortably
on a plane and then you've got fit
people who are antagonizing fat people
for the way they look do you not think
there's a back and forth between those
two halves of what do you call
antagonize
I think like we're talking about
victimhood a lot of people who are big
and feel particularly sensitive about
being big they would see particular
comments as antagonizing whereas you
guys might see it as like a healthy bit
of bullying and it gets you to where you
want to be but people like being fat is
a very sensitive issue because it stems
from an emotional deficit and that's
something I think a lot of people would
accept as being true so if it stems from
an emotional deficit you know that it's
a sensitive side I think I think I think
fit people are trying to help
I think most fit people I mean I've even
offered I said any day you guys want to
work out 11AM 11 A.M coming I swear to
God I'll do it even even even one of my
my Purdue one of my my other producer
struggles with his weight I make him go
up the stairs with me like like I think
most fit people that I don't make if he
does it out of his Free Will don't don't
clip that but but no but like most fit
people will help you like most fit
people are encouraging but like I just
think we get to a point where fat people
don't want to talk about what's reality
yeah and the reality is it is an early
grave the reality is you shouldn't be
content at it as is the reality is a lot
of people will have problems because of
the choices that you make and that's
denied that though but but I I would say
maybe did
I'm not saying they're denying it I'm
saying the movement in general I'm not
talking about you guys personally says
to be content as is and focuses on
Mental Health I don't think we should
focus on Mental Health I think we should
focus on physical health first I just
think that both things can exist at once
and that's my standpoint like I I think
that you can want to be better and you
can improve yourself and you can also
not hold yourself back from things that
you want to do and with the plain seat
thing that's that's a really complicated
one because I can empathize with the
pain that they must feel how
embarrassing that must be and I can
understand the jerk reaction to be like
oh this needs to just be bigger I
understand that but like when I can go
down a slide my thought was not this
slide should be bigger right it was I
should be smaller like this is not
normal that I can't go down this slide
but I've also sat on a plane before
where I've had a bigger person next to
me and they've apologized for their
weight and I felt really sad that they
felt like they had to do that don't
don't you think like all of these
adjustments are enabling it like making
bigger clothes making bigger seats
making like putting models in the media
like is it in a way it's enabling it the
same way it's the same the same way
handing alcohol and making it easy easy
to drink is enabling an alcoholic
people used to train to fit in a wedding
dress a couple years ago now people used
to go to The Outpost country and be like
listen I want to get in this wedding
dress I want to be at a certain weight
everyone still does that no I think
there are plus size uh no no no no no
come on 60 60 of us are overweight like
they do die when people get married they
I don't know anyone who's got married
and not tried to lose weight for their
wedding day no [__] but Pearl's question
was is it enabling people to get fed up
to a degree no I don't I don't think
that anybody like I have a lot of skinny
friends most of my friends are skinny
and I don't think any of my skinny
friends have ever looked at me and been
like do you know what I'd like to get a
father they've never it's just never
happened it's enabling you it's enabling
you they're not saying I want to get
fatter they're saying because you're
seeing it everywhere oh and it's okay we
can do this that it's enabling them to
get further I
consciously I can still honestly like
because I mean my big thing is I have a
sugar addiction I kind of like it when
people like when I'm eating something
bad and someone says something to me
about it like because I'm like yeah I
probably shouldn't like I think it's
helpful makes you feel guilty yeah yeah
and and I think those things are part of
normal conversations though I don't
think there's anything necessarily wrong
with that specifically like my boyfriend
is skinny and I'll say that to him
because he has a major Sweet Tooth and
he eats a lot of crap like and I'll be
like that is your second piece of cake
today you know like and he's not fat
like I think that's a normal question
but I think we're both mentally stable
people you can't say that to everybody
skinny people but have a high visceral
fat yeah
that's a huge thing that is missed out
in the body positivity movement and I
think it gets to a point where we have
to stop it's much deeper don't worry how
they want to be helped and help them how
they need to be helped it's like we
talked about it earlier right when
people have a really serious drug
addiction there comes a point where your
loved ones you have like a bit of an
intervention right and you your people
they sit you down they say you need help
you're going to die your kids need you
around so off you go you're going to
rehab for six to 12 months and you're
not coming back until you sort yourself
out so at what point do we stop helping
people how they want to be helped and
help them how they need to be helped how
do fat people need to be helped
well it depends on the person but you
said no no they want to be that's out so
depending on the person is how they
would want to be helped no it depends
people in general need to be helped do
the government need to come in and say
okay no more McDonald's
a plus-sized model how could people
encourage what is the best way to
encourage people to lose weight
but me I found what I did encourage a
lot of people a lot of people were like
oh yeah I should lose weight too from
the video I made there was a really
positive video about wanting to help
myself like I got a lot of positive
response from that I got a little
negative response from people being like
it makes me really sad that you call
yourself fat because I'm bigger than you
because I made a few jokes I I picked
fun at myself and I called myself fat in
the video and that made some people feel
bad well you should tell them they're
fat too and they should work they should
work out it's not how I think though I
just don't think like that and I don't
think I would argue that I don't think
accommodating is necessarily enabling in
the same way if you want to compare it
to drug addiction I would say that there
are healthy ways to use drugs and like I
think it's in the Netherlands they have
places you can go where you can shoot up
with clean needles and things like that
and I think that harm reduction is much
better than just saying no it's like
celibacy it just doesn't work no I mean
as like I I had I had a cousin that died
from like drug addiction I'm sorry to
hear that I mean it's okay it was a
while ago but I just don't think that
enabling's like I wouldn't look at
someone that gave him drugs in a healthy
way and say oh thank you for that I I
think I think it was it would actually
be a negative thing I think there's a
difference between enabling and
accommodating and and one is realistic
yeah is it a means to an end
accommodating and like
um safe usage that's a means to an end
right the end is that you'd hope that
the person stops using drugs
accommodating fatness the end is that
you hope that the person yeah so in the
same vein how is a person going to stop
using drugs if they've been given it
safely and how is a fat person gonna
stop getting fat or maintain his weight
if he doesn't stop or he or she doesn't
stop eating
interesting thing that came across
recently was as a plus size model I was
thinking like I want to make my own
brand I want to invest a lot of money
into something and start producing
something I thought about making plus
size lingerie I thought that making plus
size clothes for some financial advisors
I spoke to a few people and everybody
told me do not do it because there's no
money in staying fat like that is what I
was told by professionals they were like
the money isn't losing weight but why
because he asked you a question like
what's the best way to help fat people
isn't it diet and exercise
well go ahead
the best way to lose weight is
to first start telling yourself that
it's one step at a time one step at a
time
um have a plan give yourself okay
imagine I do 10 sit ups today tomorrow
I'm gonna go for 15. if it's too hot I'm
gonna do 15 on the third day then I'm
gonna push myself to do 20 and along
with that he's even trying new foods and
just eating fresh things the diet and
extreme it's diet and exercise but a lot
of people that don't lose the weight is
because of mobility issues so it's again
if I can't do this with my knee what can
I do how can I move my eyes not everyone
has a mobility issue like for the last
three years like governments have put
out ad campaigns you should you should
take this it's safe or you know smoking
ads are put up on television would you
guys be opposed to a government ad
saying if you continue eating this way
you're gonna die that's why they have
Mercy
losing weight is 20 Fitness and it's 80
nutrition so when you're talking about
Mobility
um it has nothing to do with sit-ups it
has to do with running or in the gym is
is 80 diet anyway so
if you want to lose weight then nobody
80 percenters nobody 20 percenters and
you personalize your program to that
also when people if you want to do
something I need to I need to comment
because there are a couple of things
that I want to push back on from
something that Pierre said it goes back
to every like a lot of these things tie
back to each other you said both things
can exist at the same time that that in
my opinion is a very wrong ideology
because
if you say you can want to lose weight
and at the same time enjoy your body the
weight is in its current state I I think
that is you actually stopping yourself
from actually losing weight because both
things can't actually exist at the same
time it goes back to the same thing we
talk about on this podcast where women
want everything you can't have
everything in life so if you really want
to lose weight you need to
um
how will I put it you need to basically
starve yourself of certain things
those things and trying to lose weight
because you wouldn't lose weight so for
instance like you said the beginning
should be earned when you stop yourself
from wearing a bikini till you earn it
you would actually get that goal you're
saying this but if you yeah but if
you're if you're
able to wear the bikini on a Sunday and
say you're gonna go to the gym on Monday
you're not going to work as hard in the
gym I think that you're confusing like
um Aesthetics and health that because
for me those things aren't particularly
linked I want to lose weight because I
want to be healthy but I don't dislike
the way that I like I'm not confusing it
I'm not confusing you know why because a
lot of times we try to be
um deeper than we actually should be a
lot of these things are actually very
soft trying to make it more complex
before you can talk about all these
things about the mind or your eyes are
the first thing that you used to see so
your your brain is going to work on what
it sees so no matter what you try to
tell yourself in your head
your eyes to see what you look like and
that's the reason why I wanted to ask
the question to the personal trainers
because it's very funny people asked
what is the best way to lose weight and
with all due respect I don't think
um you're in the right position to
answer that question um no but what he
did say partially was correct I know but
the reason why I'm saying that is
because this is the thing you
um it's like
that question should have been answered
by the personal trainers in my opinion
because one they have worked with people
that have helped people lose weight so
they know if even if
if you haven't done it you saying it is
kind of like okay
it's it kind of counteracts your
arguments there are personal trainers
who actually don't understand
injuries they don't literally they don't
understand it because they keep on
working with fit people and that's why
they just ain't nobody no there's a lot
of there's a lot of locally like yeah
like people because there's something
you said no this thing that makes me
know
because you said something like when you
go to the gym it's scary you see these
people working out the reality is
because I worked in the gym the reality
is some the fittest people are actually
the most important okay okay because
they've had to do the hard work they
know just last night that's why we do
just last week I think what you do what
you've done essentially is you've you
put a mental block on yourself so you
see things that are actually not there
you go into the gym you see people
looking at you and you think oh my God
they're judging me the reality is most
people don't even care about other
people okay so I joined the gym a week
and a half ago in Essex now it's my
induction and some things obviously I
know how to use because I use it but
because I want to improve myself
I was like so are you going to show me
around like he's like yeah that's that
that's that and I'm like it's finally
going to show me how to use it because I
at least want to use it and then he goes
well you're not going to use it are you
I'm like why am I joining then I'm like
you need you shouldn't be working my
literally talking yeah that's what my
experience yeah that's just a bad
experience I know but no but it happens
a lot and it's not a lot because that's
what I mean by encouragement that when
people aren't used to working with hey
hey 11 A.M tomorrow you come
to say this I was just going to say this
this you offered this same thing the
last time it was here and between then
and now we haven't seen you here can I
say why can I can I tell you why why my
dad's got cancer and he's been in
hospital and this week I actually gave
him his sponge bath and
when you're gonna lose a father
and when you're seeing them deteriorate
you're in like
it's like I've just been going it's like
I don't have any emotions so sorry to
hear about I've just been keeping busy
and a part of keeping busy is I know I
need to drink water and and actually
care for myself which is keeping active
and getting good sleep and literally
eating healthy and that's the way I'm
living now and when I go to work stuff
that you see on Instagram Tick Tock
events and stuff like that I only go
there get the picture done take a few
say hello to a few people and leave and
then I wake up I've been hospital then
I've got errands to do
I cook and clean at home I do I do the
caring when my when my nephews are here
I'm an uncle I actually read books to
them I teach them how to cook because I
want them to have real skills so when
they go out and I take them out to like
we learn about things nature all these
things so you don't have any personal
time for yourself
I don't actually know and and that's the
thing when when P when someone's losing
their life
or they will hopefully they don't you
just have to be positive and there needs
to be that okay and I'm someone who
cares about my dad and I have and I have
a lot of like empathy for that but it's
like you're sitting on a couch for three
hours here so it kind of just shows
where your priorities are but can I say
something you've been here like TW and
you know keep coming you know you're
very good content social media as well
nothing nothing like personal but it
kind of shows like where your priorities
are because you have time
with that sounding rude as much as I
love this podcast when Romeo asked me I
was at Romeo
because I actually really wanted to
watch yeah and don't you not because why
because it helps me keep active I'm
gonna dance I'm gonna be like grooving I
swear it's I have a good time podcast
ain't really me but coming on your
podcast because I enjoy you yeah oh I'm
actually I'm not
my point is my point isn't about the
podcasting it's just I think we all make
choices
right sorry I just need to I want to
share personal experience so this might
help you
um when I started working here I went
through certain personal things in my
life which I'm not going to dispute and
disclose but I think Pearl knows a few
of them but the point I'm trying to make
is for the longest time even after that
I started getting my life back on track
I wasn't working out I'm someone you
might look at me you might think I'm fit
but I'm only just starting to get my
fitness back but the reality is the
reason why I wasn't working out was
because of all this life stress and all
of that and even when I
kind of started getting my life on track
I still wasn't working out but reality
is because that was happening because I
wasn't prioritizing it once I started I
got punched in the ribs one was sparring
the other day and I kind of woke up and
I was like you know what I'm gonna make
time for the gym and I have been able to
create the time so the reality is no
matter what you're going through in life
you can always create time for the
things that are most important do you
know what it is
most of my life I've been in bed most of
my life okay so being active is actually
a thing can I can I just add to that
I just want to ask one question what's
the what's the one thing that you spend
most money on
when you don't have time
travel and food travel and food would
you say that if you want to lose weight
and get better why not spend that money
on a nutritionist
so whereas is not physical is something
a little bit more personalized program
where this person can help you even if
you don't have time which is what Bill's
saying priorities listening to you guys
I know why I am also plus size is
because literally I am busy and I've
always been busy which is fine and I'm
just fine and
I can't fully share how it is for me
because I'm once I do my goals that I
need to do my career that's why I can
share my story about
I've suffered and I suffer and I don't
take mental health as an excuse I hear
what mental health experts have got to
say but to me I'm like no if I hear what
mental health experts have to say
although I go through it I'm like no
because if I hear that that's it I'm
falling into and the Brain I learned the
power
the power of the brain you can really
push yourself there's there are things
like and um tomorrow let's push yourself
come on
to get on a coach 11 A.M the next time I
just remember there is always a way and
do not okay I understand yes yes you're
right there's no way um I'm stressing
and suffering
I don't want to play Devil's Advocate
but like you know I think everyone
suffers everyone has a point of suffer
of course would you guys say that
overweight people tend to have more
excuses
I think just in this like conversation
we could say yes
sometimes I'm not gonna lie when when
you're not feeling it it's like when
you're big you're always constantly
feeling heavy and even like exercising
is heavy and then the muscle pain in
five minutes
I could say the say I have a sugar
addiction right and there's this
um there's a like sort of a nutrition
guy that like texts me and he's like
how's your sugar and I'm like bad bad
and it's because of my own choices it's
because I lack discipline that's it it's
because I lack discipline and I keep
making that choice to put pure sugar
coffee there is that but how about I
tell you when you when like and now that
I've got it on like I'm better but in
the past when I've exercised that
exercise session will put me into bed
for a week I wouldn't be able then we
gotta figure out so that's why I've been
walking that's why I say my best way of
is this but so so we got to figure out
maybe it's diet maybe it's just diet
like I know what it is it's me it's me
actually what what do you guys think is
more effective someone being strict in
the gym or strict with their diet diet
for sure been saying it you don't even
need to go gym
yeah no no but even when you were saying
like you're one of your number one
expenses is food like I I notice when my
food bill is high that's when I gain
weight because I've been eating out
actually healthy food gas
okay look at the average juice you want
to buy a good and a a natural pressed
juice and you want to buy that much
water yes okay yeah how do you drink
water I do and I love I love juice and
sugar dry like that's like my My
Kryptonite so I get it but at the end of
the day it's just a choice like we could
drink water it is a choice and
addictions people do have addictions
it's different for different people how
I've got willpower some people may not
and it's just the way it is I think
there's a lot more willpower for a lot
of people they think that the willpower
is in going to the gym but it is
actually in what you eat because I I
think one of the super chats said this
and this was the point I was going to
make you you have to discipline the one
thing you rely on right we're talking
about drug addiction we're talking about
smoking people don't need to smoke to
live but you do need to eat to live
thing is you cannot out exercise a poor
diet right because there's only so many
hours in the day and your body has a
physical limit you could eat 12
cheeseburgers and then like get on the
treadmill for as long as you can and you
know you can't really you can't out
exercise the 12 cheeseburgers that you
ate which is why it probably does need
to start with diet and we were talking
about companies and corporate social
responsibility earlier look at how much
uh like the cheapest burger from
McDonald's is like less than a pound or
something or at least it was
um but then if you go and buy like a lot
of people would compare and I've seen
this all over Instagram like McDonald's
is really cheap compared to fruit or
vegetables or a gym membership and
that's what a lot of people
who like really support the body
positivity movement would come back with
like it's about cost and and convenience
and that's why going back to foreign
honestly my dad he he's always been like
thinner like in shape pretty much like
never really struggled with it he lives
on fast food but he just doesn't need a
lot some people are just blessed no he's
not blessed he just runs and do you
think
also eats a lot of like chicken from
those places do you think being fat is a
result of your environment too because
my dad partial my dad runs a gym and
that's how I got into the gym
do you guys feel like maybe it's because
of the environment of course actually
that's that's my my next one question I
had is is is
yes obesity for children child abuse
absolutely
right hold on Obesity for children yes
if a child's obese is because the adult
is feeding them yes
if they're not aware no because some
because some grandparents are like my
child has to eat they have to have this
they have to have that
I noticed so you guys all said yes
immediately do you feel like you're in
the position you're in because you were
fed bad food as a child absolutely not
because and I I said this last time I
hate to sound repetitive for the people
who love the show but like your
circumstances may not be your fault but
it's your responsibility to change it
I just correct right but I'm saying like
when you were younger did that were you
always big or did you get big when you
were older
um I was smaller when I was younger and
then it just like every year like I've
just gotten bigger okay I was just
wondering if the food you ate at home
affected that or no I think to a degree
it did but I think a lot of it is just
adult okay like uh I really think fried
chicken and chicken and chip shops in
East London ruin into me
no I'm just being honest because growing
up in my household there was fish there
was vegetables there was everything and
it was home cooked and my mom was always
health conscious as well so it is what's
it's again it just goes to show if you
grew up in a community where there are
things like that and they're promoted
and they're cheap you will eat it and
you will get big and that's what exactly
will happen
um what do you guys think child abuse
100 yeah for sure I'd say like it's a
parent's responsibility to care for
their kids and if you're getting to a
point where they're extremely unhealthy
or obese then it is child abuse oh my
God yes guys I mean I have a niece back
home and every time
my parents
and they're feeding that time like don't
give her too much of macaroni don't give
out too much of this on that like make
sure she's eaten small portions make
sure she's eternality so your your
family's obese
what is this like conversations like
with you no no no no I mean I'm saying
my niece yeah when I see them feeding
her no you just every time you've been
on the show a couple times you always
mention you're overweight like family
so I'm just wondering like what do you
do what are your conversations like like
do you tell them my family yeah all the
time okay like even my cousin that died
she saw the last um podcast and she even
came to me and she was like oh my God
everything you guys was talking about
was right I was like great so you should
be giving yourself that that type of
advice
but again it wasn't up to me yeah it was
up to her to take that advice by myself
you know what I mean one of the
um things that I would say on terms of
like children like I was a skinny kid
like I grew up skinny uh but one thing
that I will never do that my parents
even me that I think a lot of parents do
of people who get overweight as adults
is um food was like a reward if I did
well at school I got to go for a nice
dinner
um I got a treat if I did good at
something and so when I was in
university in like drama school and I
got into this binge Purge restrict
routine
um that was partly where like the
dopamine Rush came from eating junk food
was because when I grew up because I ate
some healthy as a kid junk food was a
reward and when I have kids like I'd
like to have a much healthier and if
they do well in the exam like I would
never take them for a meal to celebrate
that I'd do something else that was part
of my issue okay
what do you think I feel like it's child
abuse only because the child has no
control over what they can or cannot eat
at the end of the day your parent will
cook for you and then they'll be like
there's the food on the table go and eat
so where you were saying that you were
rewarded like when you were being like
good or whatever my dad he's an athlete
so if when the moment I started putting
away he would just say nope he used to
make me do four laps around a track I
used to see him four laps that's it and
the slower I got he'll be
I'll be reprimanded again you'll be
there oh well like it wouldn't be good
for me in any shape or form so for me I
feel like I've taken a lot of sacrifices
I haven't always been this size I used
to be once a lot bigger and then because
of my diagnosis I said to myself listen
I have to make the sacrifice so I became
vegan and informed that that's where I
started to lose more weight as well I
need to be as light as possible so that
I can manage my condition as well as
other people so if I have a relapse
tomorrow and I'm like what 200 kilograms
or 120 kilograms or whatever I'm gonna
be a lot harder to manage than If I Was
80 kilograms do you get on Tennessee so
for me personally
you have to kind of think of the
longevity of your life
otherwise
you know
there's no value in them
I have a question for the bodybuilders
bodybuilders yeah um if someone wanted
to lose weight wait which Step do you
because I hear there's a lot that you
need to attack it from both sides do
everything but I actually don't think
that's correct I think you have to start
somewhere right so somewhere to start
would you advise them to
change that diet first or go to the gym
first if it's on a base person I'm
saying ease yourself into it that you
don't have to go nuts in the gym
straight off the bat I think you've got
to go die at first like like the guys
that said 80 diet 20 exercise diet first
easy way into it go then then move your
way into exercise walking then
resistance training slowly you know
other forms of equipment but you have to
work up towards it your body's going to
react pretty suddenly to it but
definitely die at first and the reason
to that is um the first thing I'll do
with our client is I'll put them on the
most gym sub skills right and these
skills give you um certain numbers
when your clients see these numbers now
you have to explain to them what
category they're in you know this is
healthy this is heading into the danger
zone or this is alarming
and that is by diet
there's not much that the gym could do
with these numbers so now you have to
explain to this person okay
yes we're gonna start trading and this
is the particular type of training that
you will be doing or no because of what
because of the lifestyle that your your
doing right now it needs to change and
because of it that you have right now it
needs to change because whatever you're
doing right now is a causing these
numbers to grow and to get into the
alarm in range so I'd say 100
um that
sure
I thought it was a personal trainer as
well
oh okay now about 100 no I feel like
it's more so director are you not a
trainer
no 100 I feel like Diet first and then
after that it would be like exercising
so because you need to create some sort
of sustainable lifestyle for yourself so
you need to ease yourself into it and be
able to like you know micromanage
yourself into you know what I'm trying
to say you know I swearing about that we
actually disagree with all three of them
I think you're wrong I mean I can prove
you wrong as well but you could prove
you want to try it you wanna you want us
to go
you take one fat person I'll take
another fat person let's say you get the
best results
okay 11 A.M tomorrow but in terms of
like the discussion the reason why I say
I think that's that's well I wouldn't
say it's inquiry because there's no
right way to anything but the reason why
I don't think that's the most optimal
way is because
um
one
companies benefit from this whole
ideology behind dieting so if you look
at where the money goes usually you
should go in the opposite direction so
um
I always think of it like this if I have
to pay money for anything I'll rather do
the thing that's free
going to working out is free you can go
for a run on the road you can do all of
that and the reason why I think working
out is better first is because
I think it's more sustainable and it
gives you more of a feedback than
dieting dieting is very broad it's like
it's almost like when you say dieting
most people are confused they don't even
know what you're talking about nice I
have a question but the reason why I
think working out is actually more
important is because if you go to the
gym every day and you're able to stay
consistent with that your body will give
you feedback one two the harder it gets
it will get harder first before it gets
easier right yeah but that will motivate
the same the same goes for a diet though
the reason why I'm trying to make this
point is because these days when when uh
an era where people Hammer so much on
mental health and all this crap right I
actually agree that these are the things
that hindering people from achieving
these goals right the reality is you
cannot have a strong mind without a
strong body first right but both require
discipline having a good diet and and
exercising regularly but you still have
to build a strong body to get to the
strong mentors you gotta get you've got
to get yourself to a point to build the
strong body
yeah but you're still eating like a pig
Yeah the more you keep exercising the
more the discipline comes because that's
if you're working hard at exercise and
you're seeing that you're still putting
on this effort you can't get into your
goals and your body is still giving you
that
um feedback of you do this and it's
painful you would want to improve in
other areas to make that endeavor easier
yeah
you could burn a thousand calories and
eat 4 000 calories it just I think you
got to start with your diet first yeah
I'm sorry go ahead I was gonna say how
disagree and agrees because if you start
having that consistency and discipline
yes you're gonna get stronger
um you're gonna get stronger mindsets
you're gonna get fitter body but then
when you continue eating poor diet and
they're definitely not gonna change but
what it is what I'm saying when you work
out what it will do
the part that I agree on is because of
that discipline and consistency it is
going to encourage you to eat healthier
because you now start feeling better you
know start feeling better it will
encourage you to eat more healthy and
that's the part I agree on you on
um but still that I mean diet wins
even when I started working out again I
I was saying for the longest time I'm
going to stop visiting this I didn't
actually stop until I started going to
the gym yeah so because they didn't go
in the stairs
actually the start of everything yeah
yeah you see that you see the elevator
we do the stairs
no you're a little bit more conscious on
your diet though right yeah yeah yeah
that's in the process of I've really
tried to lose weight I find it much
easier to eat better on days I've worked
out that morning because I have this
whole thing in my head of like I don't
want to do it I don't want to do it I
don't want to do it you know whereas if
I haven't worked out that day I'm like
well you know I mean it is easier but
the diet is the more effective thing
like I used to never ever do this but
when I was uh skinnier I used to do
water fasts
um particularly for roles or for
auditions when I was an actor I would
water fast for like five days and I
would lose like two pounds a day could
not be me yeah I don't know I would say
that that's like that takes a lot of
discipline it's very very hard but like
I was like not okay when I did that do
you guys think that weight loss programs
are toxic
toxic
if they if they include
um taking non-natural things yeah but if
it's natural and if it's just using your
own way and equipment that is no harm to
you then no it's not toxic only gets
toxic when you add the drugs I think
it's the execution of the weight loss
program that makes it not necessarily
toxic but unhelpful
um and it doesn't serve the individuals
what about the company what about the
biggest loser
eight to ten obese people
get pair them up with personal trainers
prominent personal trainers and they
would see who would lose the most weight
did they gain it back very entertaining
show a lot a lot it did I would love to
watch if that came back I might even go
anywhere but a lot of a lot of the
personal trainers we have one in
Australia we can make our own version we
should do it yeah yeah yeah but a
personal trainer back in Australia who
was on the show Michelle Bridges got
canceled because she would have a go at
magazines Media or pushing body
positivity and larger women on magazines
and I think the same thing happened with
a US personal trainer on The Biggest
Loser yeah it did that's her field she's
in Fitness
should she even be getting canceled for
saying this is unhealthy no
no cancel but I think it it just it's
about sensitivity again right it's this
um
it's the fact that we want to sort of
Molly cuddle people into we want to wrap
them in Cotton wool and protect their
feelings and if a personal trainer is on
you know a bit more of the brutal side
and their approach is a little bit more
boot camp-esque they are less palatable
less desirable to people who are
potentially not as serious as as serious
about their goals or people who just
don't take kindly to being shouted a bit
Yeah so we've seen there's no what you
see as whole uh she said execution not
in that there is a lot in how you say it
yeah yeah and how weight loss programs
like approach things I like it when my
trainer is a little mean to me just a
little bit
um
you know it's kind of like the teacher
you like the one that's a bit strict you
know yeah
no no I just think you know otherwise
I'll otherwise I'll I'll cancel the
personal training you know if if they
don't yell at me I'll I'll be your
outlines if you're not hard on them they
will concert yeah especially if they if
you cancel and they're like oh it's okay
no it's not okay stop letting me do that
even if you charge me yeah I agree I'm
tired
generally in love are you more dominant
or like would you say
um would you say you're more dominant or
you're more on the opposite of dominance
what's submissive you know it depends on
the environment I played sports for a
while so I would say it's Sports I was
more as an athlete yeah you would rather
a coach that is strict and part of the
same do you want to play for the coach
yeah so yeah when you bring up our
workout routines toxic
at the end of the day it's up to the
individual if you don't like the way
they're executing it you can leave go to
the next personal trainer absolutely but
you know you want someone that's going
to keep you accountable at the end of
the day yeah [__] sucks it depends on
the waitlist program because as I said
earlier there are places like Slimming
World which are almost designed to keep
you in them forever they want you to
leave and then gain weight and come back
and a lot of things are like that well
what's a non-toxic weight loss program
to you guys nutritionist personal
trainer's healthy because you've got to
keep that in the long term but these
like um fast lost like accountability
weight loss things they're all supposed
to help each other like Slimming World
and Weight Watchers I think that they
make a lot of money of the same people
find nutritionist my mom lost like 50
pounds on Weight Watchers is that a bad
one
do you know what toxic toxic health is
muscle and Health Muscle meals and
health foods toxic then it's the same as
Weight Watchers we have a thing in
Australia called The Man shake for men
that are overweight the dad Bots they
instead of having a meal
is that bad couldn't you argue that
everything like 80 of people gain the
weight back so no it like I I don't
think there's any weight loss program
that's that successful which is my next
question is why do you think that is
because it shouldn't be
uh short-term eight-week weight loss
program it should just be a lifestyle
change
that's what it is so that was my
question for the trainers why do 80 of
people gain the weight back
yeah
diets it's thought yeah it'd be probably
dieting fat dieting intermittent fasting
thing and this is going to solve the
problem it's really just about
consistency and doing whatever yeah
that you're consistently having as soon
as you change adaptation like as soon as
you you break that it could it changes
but that's why diets don't work that's
my point no but what John said it is
literally you need to change your life
the mindset of one but listen to me one
thing to actually be aware of what
you're eating drinking diets don't work
and I'll tell you why because it's
almost like saying the human we are not
designed to eat like you can't say
someone should eat the same thing for
because if you lose your weight on diets
then you're gonna have to maintain it
with that diet and you can't stay on
that same diet for the rest of your life
so the idea is if you lose weight on
this diet eventually you're going to go
back to eating whatever you liked eating
you know the reality is if you build
your body to the point where because I
don't I don't eat healthy I hear we're
trying I don't eat all of that the
reason why I'm able to stay and keep my
body fit is because I've played Sports
all my life I've been in the gym almost
all my life and even for like the past
three four years that I I didn't step in
the gym for a single hour all the work
I've done prior to that is what is
sustaining me so feta people have a
higher metabolism yes metabolism is it
the reason why people stay obese is
because their metabolism slows down it
stops and the only way to that's it
metabolism is to move exactly you need
to move your body you can do whatever
diet you like it is never going to work
yeah but people without consistency
though yeah 100 that has to be
consistent at the same time so yeah you
can say diets don't work or and whatever
metabolism is the reason why people stay
fat but at the end of the day it's
personal accountability yeah keeping
yourself in a calorie deficit for a long
period of time it's very simple you know
what I was thinking about when you said
the average like job are you sacrificing
your health you kind of are because
you're sitting for eight hours a day
there's ways to stay healthy you can no
there are but until like the average
person in a way in Corporate America you
do like they don't really I worked in
Corporate America okay they didn't look
healthy a lot of them yeah Wall Street
do a lot of cocaine as well well you
know that's a different problem
we'd fit people they do a lot of coke
that's one thing for sure you know I've
never seen a person do this
that everyone always has the sniffles
wow
I could never come there like the
corporate nine to five has a standard
tree lifestyle I think it's called where
you're just behind the desk
every job has its uh yeah and it's just
like you know that's work I think with
uh weight loss programs like Weight
Watchers and Slimming World they
actually ultimately end up disempowering
people because I can't remember which
one it is and I don't know if they still
do it but they attribute what they call
sins to like good foods and bad foods
and they don't actually talk about
calories so the person who's on the
weight loss program becomes attached to
this concept of sins but that's really
unhelpful because you might say an
orange has two sins but chocolate bar
has one and it doesn't actually help you
evaluate the nutritional profile of
either one and so where these programs
become I don't know if I'd say toxic but
unhelpful is where you're not actually
giving people the numbers and you're not
giving them the data if you have the
knowledge then you can make the choices
it's knowledge and choices we need to
educate people
well I think the question was uh
um sort of like was it workout programs
and stuff like are they helpful or toxic
and I think that some of them can be
unhelpful if it's something like why do
we why do we skip nutrition as they go
to weight loss programs
I can't answer that question because I
haven't done that yeah it's all a
business money money money they bring
all the Honeys it's all the business
guys
why do we escape the right people to go
to the people that [__] and everyone
I wonder if it's yeah it's it's the BS
right you want things to be you know pun
intended but you want it easy yeah sugar
coated as a nutritionist is like a
long-term solution it's also cheap to go
to Weight Watchers in Slimming World
it's not that cheap I think the personal
nutritionist in comparison to going to
these weekly groups the nutrition the
nutritionists are a bit more
personalized
it is more expensive but I think it's a
bit I know like we're talking about
smoking and drug addiction and if being
obesity it's like a food addiction is
there AA for fat people
I know I she did there's something it's
not that popular it's not that kind of
they go around the room I've been fat
for this yeah it's like an online
community I just know my aunt actually
said something to me she lost like a ton
of weight through it yeah wow wow I
don't at least it's fat people keeping
each other accountable yeah yeah it's um
ah gosh I wish I could remember the name
there there's something like that though
I don't know if they're in person
meetings though I think it's like online
Zoom yeah I think people get scared if
they saw a group of 12 fat people like
huddled together it'd be like a bit of a
fat cult I think
oh my God I mean I think that's like the
average American woman was a fat I just
can't well maybe that would just be that
would just be a normal day I was there
in South Beach last week and like come
from Australia to in going into Florida
seeing the amount of people that are
overweight is crazy like it is a
epidemic over there the amount of these
people there are and it's just like just
the average person looks overweight just
the average person oh my gosh but when I
see a group of big people together it
does genuinely scare me because I know
how much I weigh I've broken a lot of
beards plastic I'm scared of plastic
seeds so I'm scared of like little
things like that and so when I see a
group of big people although I don't
discriminate because I know how much
I'll be in the things that are broken
when they come together is scary also
I'll have another fear big women in
heels are scared I'm scared for them
just in case it snaps and it's not even
that and I actually saw someone in it it
happened to me on the bus and I thought
the way of the shoulder on my feet and
I'm never gonna forget it and now when I
see big person I'm always that kind of
like oh I I wanna I wanna try and catch
you just in case you fall can I just be
real like I have no idea character or
like a
real life experiences here this is not a
joke oh my God I am a real person would
you be afraid if they came in in heels
no not like that you know like imagine
wearing like a party or something and
the dogs next to me no but if I saw the
stick was just like a pencil no that is
scary for me and this is not a
discrimination this is like literally
health and safety for myself because I
felt someone shoulder on my foot
you guys am I making you guys laugh
sorry I didn't know I didn't know plus
size seals were a thing
she just said she just said there are
things if they were a pencil scene you
know what I'm talking about well so uh a
person who is rational and actually
cares about their safety I don't say
health and safety but someone who cares
about their safety like you're not gonna
catch me in a stiletto because I'd have
the same fit that is gonna snap
yeah but like you make the the right
choices and they are there are actually
Hills for bigger people that are
designed to hold your weight
everything's World
accommodations that have to be made
right
plus size heels are enabling
okay okay just imagine if you guys
couldn't buy clothes anywhere I just
think you might lose weight quicker yeah
like if you couldn't if I think I'd just
be naked wouldn't I if I couldn't buy
clothes
if I couldn't buy clothes anywhere the
first thing I would be is naked okay
okay I think you'd make arrangements
you'd get some cloths and then you'd
start losing weight to buy clothes
elsewhere yeah you'd make arrangements
it's like I want someone to work out
with me so bad I'm always by myself
welcome yeah
11 A.M tomorrow
so I can't come some days okay okay I've
got Doms right now I was at the gym
yesterday I haven't been in the gym for
ages well you say nice it bloody hurts
like it's supposed to be a reward isn't
it like when you've got um
yeah they they say that but it's bloody
hurts and I think I just pushed myself
too hard my we were talking about what
the Tipping Point is for someone who's
Big like at what point do you change
your life for me I just realized that I
wasn't as it was a Mobility thing I
wasn't as flexible as I used to be and I
was like wait I could do that before
with no issue and now like it I can
still do it but it's an effort so I went
to the gym
I threw my back out helping someone else
like being some sort of emergency spot
thinking that I could do something I
couldn't save the guy threw my back out
um but then I went to the gym yesterday
and worked out it was great it was
really fun
but I think I just like I let it go for
so long that I didn't lift weights and
then I thought I did something really
easy I was doing like 18 kilos on
various weight machines and it was fine
at first like when I was in the gym I
was like yeah this is the easiest light
work let me you know hike up to 24 32
but today I'm in so much pain and that
is another
um like unintended outcome of just not
going to the gym for ages a lot of
people think yeah I'll just gain a bit
of weight but actually it gets harder
and it's there comes a point where it's
I won't say that you know you're too far
gone because people have been 600 pounds
and and gone the other way but it
definitely becomes harder and I think a
lot of people develop this mindset that
they are too far gone
and then they just never do anything
about it yeah I've seen loads of posts
recently about famous people having
heart attacks and like I look in the
comments because I'm like well this
person's 400 pounds I I feel like I know
why they they had a heart attack I look
in the comments and people like no it's
because they had this they had that and
you know it's like you never you're
never you're never too far gone there's
always a person that's done it there's
always a person that achieved it and it
can all start at 11 A.M tomorrow
let me let you in on a little secret as
well you see that pain you felt it does
it doesn't happen to only people that
are overweight I know yeah I'm very fit
and when I went to the gym the next day
I felt like I was gonna die that is not
normal
even even when I'm at my fittest I still
feel that pain the difference is fit
people understand that that pain equals
growth yeah so other people would look
at it like ah okay now this is painful
I'm gonna stop no if you don't feel that
pain then you probably didn't even work
out yeah exactly all right so basically
Pearl you keep on talking about that
11AM
so um if you're watching earlier I would
like to play Pearl you're really
gorgeous you know I'm telling you you
need to like wear like some fashionable
clothes and then she told me to send her
a DM with the clothes that I think she
should wear so I think people should
vote but what do they want to watch you
getting dressed in a new outfit and
feeling on flat and looking cool or do
they want to watch me and you exercise I
think you should ask your followers that
because put a poll on the chat if they
pick the workout will you come what does
that have to do it come on
being dressed up in good fashion
actually celebrating yourself and
getting your features up because she
just wears clean clothes and I feel like
there's nothing wrong with it because
that's her it's not about me trying to
change her fashion it's just adding
little cuteness in a pop of color
because
she she comes across as this mean person
or whatever very opinionated but I see
right through her and she she needs
something no I'm sure all the pearls
follows one her to take fashion advice
Sugar Puff no I'm telling you yoga gonna
look hey hey let's let's we'll do a poll
we'll do all right you do the poem they
do the workout one are you coming yes
I'll do the workout well I'll attempt it
I won't I won't silence
if they choose the fashion one are you
gonna go and and I'm not because you're
buying them I'm just shopping them for
you that's fine that's fine all right
okay that's cool wow a hundred percent
says losing weight
all right